a little crazy
i first of all i don't even know
how like
you have a technique what's my technique
you just throw one liners and blow up a
party can i milk the goat with my mouth
what you don't drink it from the other
why don't do that but whatever maybe i
do i don't know
[Music]
i'm glad you and kiki talked and
everything's
[Music]
nice seeing you nice to see you good
gorgeous okay so we're actually talking
about the other day and i don't want to
talk behind your back so i would like to
talk with you my love is good please
perfect so let's go chat along with our
audience
[Music]
so um sometimes i can just say
you know i'm a little over at the top
sometimes but it's not i wasn't coming
from a mean place
and just because you said something i
didn't like doesn't mean i don't like
you because of what you said right so
there's a big difference but i really
want to apologize for whatever i say
that night it just it came from a place
where
i'm really
struggling with certain things right now
it literally just broke off my
engagement
if you're going through hard stuff if i
can be of any help to you i would love
to and just to hear that coming from you
it means the world to me
are you starting fresh
good energy
oh i'm all about good energy thank you
this is so hard your tablescape is
beautiful did you do this no oh i worked
all day yesterday
you're a doctor and you know what that's
why i respect you even more
because you're a doctor and i'm married
to a doctor and i you know how the hours
crazy you guys are
this is
stunning you would never know
the depth that lies to lisa by just like
perusing her social media
she's super sweet she's an awesome mom
we've had some playdates and uh i really
enjoy her company question for you yes
two
two questions no two kids two okay is it
like exponentially
harder way harder right okay oh
everyone's like oh you have one you
should just have another one and i'm
like no i think you're lying to me
i'm excited for your wedding that sounds
like it's going to be a lot of fun let
me know if you need help planning i'm
good
well what about planning your wedding
definitely on my list of things to do i
mean nicole for all intents and purposes
my wife
as soon as we formalize it in the eyes
of god and our friends i guess it will
be different that's what makes it kind
of like a social media
honestly sorry official nicole and i are
five years together i have a son five
years like it's official
i feel like deep inside that all women
do want to get married so i'm just not
buying it like oh it's great like why
get married like this is so great it's
kind of like the opposite oh my god this
is so great let's go get married right
oh wow i need more drinks yeah it's a
lot right
[Music]
and then roll it over
whoops don't spill that drink on your
beautiful floor
[Music]
i'm so excited to go wedding grass
shopping oh my god
but i know how stressed you are yeah i
mean because i have everything else
going on also yeah you know i have
my business
and i'll have frankie that you know
takes a lot of my time oh my son peter i
have tottenham it's awesome
like when i think everything is perfect
and i'm the happiest in my life adriana
yeah
something happens and it's like what the
hell yeah what happened
unfortunately a couple of months ago
peter comes over peter likes to smoke
frankie smoked it's illegal you have a
medical license they actually say it's
very good for some brain injury
you know obviously
anxiety too for anxiety for many things
but we see them downstairs we're like
okay it's cool they're small blah blah
they come upstairs
and um
we're sitting in the dining room table
and all of a sudden frankie goes
huh and we're like his head oh my god
passed out yeah you don't understand
peter literally
had to like
bring it back to life called 9-1-1
peter was on his phone and he overlooked
the whole situation
frankie smoked a little bit too much his
blood pressure dropped and like i almost
died like you have no idea
are you kidding me
i'm sorry i can't believe i didn't even
know this
and i thought to myself marisol and
anything that you could see in a movie
to lexia's life
why would you be shocked
todd comes out
and he said a lot of me thanks to who
to peter
[Music]
you